después de semanas de intenso bombardeo
las fuerzas rusas están preparadas para
capturar se veroniask el gobernador de
la provincia de lugans que en la región
oriental ucraniana de dombas informó que
las tropas ucranianas han recibido la
orden de retirarse de la ciudad
Lamentablemente nuestros muchachos
tendrán que ser retirados permanecen en
posiciones destrozadas durante muchos
meses solo por permanecer allí no tiene
sentido
[Música]
ha quedado reducida a escombros según el
gobernador todas las infraestructuras
críticas han sido destruidas el 90% de
la ciudad está dañada y el 80% de las
casas tendrán que ser demolidas
la toma de la ciudad otorga el cremín el
control casi total de la región de
lugansk para ello tendrá que avanzar en
la ciudad cercana de Lisi chance que ha
estado enfrentando un bombardeo Ruso
cada vez más intenso los separatistas
prorrusos han dicho a las fuerzas
ucranianas que intentan defender ambas
ciudades que la resistencia ahora era
inútil y sin sentido